recently a bunch of people thought a cs
go player died in a car crash
his friends tweeted out about the news
and the community including an esea
admin
passed along their condolences except he
wasn't dead
and the whole situation was fake so what
happened here
well i got the whole story for you
[Music]
okay guys the score esports is streaming
over on twitch.tv slash the score
esports and on top of shows like clouded
and collins chess streams
we have more individual streams coming
your way like dimitri playing ballerin
on fridays
and myself talking movies and video
games this thursday july 16th
so make sure you follow the channel so
you know exactly when we go live
so on sunday june 14th a twitter account
with the handle csruff
tweeted out quote rip mijo he was a good
kid
it really sucks what happened end quote
the person he was talking about was his
friend who goes by the name
miho a cs go player with a long history
of playing on esea
now if you guys aren't cs go heads esea
is basically a platform that
for a price gives you access to better
servers in a more robust anti-cheat
system
esca also has its own amateur league
system where you and a 5 stack can sign
up to play organized cs go while ruff's
tweet was pretty low-key and mijo is by
no means well known in the cs go scene
this news quickly spiraled out of
control because the reality is
mijo wasn't dead yeah miho faked his
death
but why he did it is a little more
complicated than it seems
and we'll get to that in just a second i
promise now i've dm'd back and forth
with
ruff and to be clear he did not know
this news was fake when he originally
tweeted out
he legitimately thought his friend had
died and was told this news by people he
trusted
eventually the news caught the attention
of oh so dank who on top of having a
fantastic
handle works as a support staff for rank
s for esea
and if you guys didn't know rank s is
basically esea's highest level of
competition
a ton of pros past and present got their
start there
and i actually talked to oso denk who
was sad to hear the news about mijo
passing
especially because he just talked to him
hours before he got the news
and then around 2 30 is when i saw the
first tweet
uh from his teammate actually from
his friend or whatever it was uh saying
that he died like her was you know in a
car accident et cetera
so i reshaped him on twitter and asked
him like you know
what like you know what happened and
like you know
they're like i'm sorry to hear that um
et cetera and
he told me that his cousin said he got
hit by a drunk driver
and he and he died so that's all i had
to go on so i made that tweet of mine
just because
it sucks to see people you know passed
away in the community and it's like it
you know it's never a good thing to see
soon after that people noticed that mijo
was playing cs go
on esea and well yeah he
wasn't dead and once also dank found
that out he tweeted out that he was
disappointed such news was played for
laughs
now here is where the why he did it
comes back into play
and it is a little confusing after
people found out that miho wasn't dead
and was playing esea league matches with
his friends multiple esports news
outlets wrote about the situation
and the articles state that miho
allegedly faked his death in order to
get around a 30-day ban on his esea
account
and they attributed this fact to him but
that's not true and here's why
first off after the story blew up mijo
tweeted out that he didn't do it to get
around the 30-day ban
but because him and his friends thought
it would be funny on top of that that's
not how the esea community guidelines
work
basically mijo was given the 30-day ban
for threatening another player while
competing in a rank s
qualifier match this was his fourth ban
for threatening another player
in his eighth esa ban since 2017
and it was this latest 30-day offense
that oso dank was talking to miho about
hours before he died he reached out to
me
through discord and like asked me about
the ban and like asked me about multiple
things and like
i'm not like i'm not gonna sit there and
argue with somebody like i
i didn't really talk to him much more
after that i just i told him like you
know why he was banned and what he said
and what you know the reason is now if
you get banned from an esea
qualifier you are still allowed to
compete at esea's league with the team
that you
signed up with and i know that sounds
confusing but basically
why esea does it this way comes down to
a matter of scheduling
it only applies like really severe bands
um it's like ban evasion you can't play
league matches but with like community
conduct violations where like you get
banned from a pug or
saying something on the platform like we
still allow you to play league matches
or esa does um because
there would like there would be a lot of
scheduling problems if
if that wasn't allowed so the idea that
miho faked his own death in order to get
around a 30-day ban on his account makes
no sense
because under esea community guidelines
mijo was still allowed to play in esea's
league
which is exactly what he did which is
ultimately how he got caught
and now we've ended up here okay so
we've gotten this far
and we haven't heard from miho yet well
i dm'd him asking how this all started
and why
he decided to fake his own death and
basically he told
me that he was peer pressured into it by
a valorent teammate
and yeah he apparently signed to a
valeran team called trillium
and he's making racks so good for him i
guess
now according to osodank he doesn't
think mijo's gonna get another ban
because this happened on twitter and had
nothing to do with esea
so as mijo waits out his latest band
continuing to play cs go or valor
it's safe to say that this story is
pretty ridiculous but it's not the first
time somebody's faked a death illness or
disability in the esports or streaming
world
it feels like we're dealing with one of
these stories every six months
we covered the time that canadian
youtuber jstation faked his girlfriend's
death
and his own arrest before she came out a
few days later and basically said
this is insane i want nothing to do with
it then there was the case where once
popular team fortress 2 youtuber sketch
faked a terminal illness and then owned
up to it three years later so there you
have it another wild story of somebody
telling an outrageous
lie even if it was for a joke which i
guess is the new normal on the internet
and thinking they weren't gonna get
caught
so if you guys didn't know i'm a big fan
of
as keith would call it sports fist or
mixed martial arts
uh all types and ufc 4 was announced
over the weekend when ufc had their big
251 fight card and holy [ __ ] does it
look good
they debut ufc 4 and in my heart of
hearts i know it's going to be the exact
same game that i played three years ago
but i am so [ __ ] excited for this
mainly because you can now
there's like backyard brawls because
jorge mossman
that's where you gotta start was in the
backyard and then like they got some
blood sports [ __ ] where you're fighting
in like an underground arena in a cave